Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 26th,
2016 what's going on?
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
It's the last Monday of fucking 2016.
George Michael passed away on Christmas Day.
Um,
wake me up before you'd go go condolences to him.
And uh,
you know what the best thing about 2016 being over is,
is,
um,
you know longer you're going to have to listen to people blaming a year for bad
things happening.
You know,
that's a big thing.
Fuck you.
2016.
I saw Madonna tweeted that.
Fuck you.
2016.
You fucking year man.
You know,
why do people keep blaming the fucking year?
it has nothing to do with the fucking year you're talking to.
There's,
there's people's genetics are involved.
There's a lifestyle choices.
There's substance abuse.
I mean,
that's what's going on here.
I don't know why you're a,
you know,
we're picking on 2016 like,
it's a,
a religion from the Middle East or something.
I have no fucking idea how it's getting the blame for all of this.
You know what I mean?
Fucking 2016 with your liver cancer,
you know,
let's blame 2016 rather than the pharmaceutical companies that fucking was
giving out opiates like Flintstone vitamins and created a fucking heroin
epidemic.
Fuck all of that.
2016 has robbed us of some of the greatest artists of our time.
2016 did like,
it's a fucking person.
How to fucking Madonna.
Madonna is world travel.
She,
she's been around the fucking world.
However you talked to enough people to not know to blame a fucking year.
Well,
maybe she's saying it metaphorically,
Bill.
I don't give a shit.
You know,
if I try to see her side that things,
how can I come up with the comedic angle to try to fill out this next fucking 60
minutes?
Fuck you.
2016 oh yeah.
You didn't like seeing the cubs finally win a world series.
Ah,
nothing good happened to you this year.
You're just going to focus on the bad.
Yeah.
Anyways,
I liked people always and try to have like a religious thing.
Like when a prince,
his backup dancers had this whole fucking religious thing that she went on
saying like,
you know,
like wake up people,
that's,
that's when you know you're out of your fucking mind.
You know,
when you start telling people to wake up like,
like you're,
you're reading the fucking a,
you're reading the tea leaves better than anybody else in your fucking,
you know,
garrison colonial,
wherever the fuck you live,
wake up people he capital h is,
is taking a robbing us of some of our greatest,
you know,
like that's a sign like all these,
these great musicians are leaving us,
which means like what?
Okay.
Like Jesus is mad at all the fucking plumbers and electricians and shit.
Granted they fucking overcharge you and they lie about when the date,
the date of whatever is going to be done,
the job's going to be done.
Um,
yeah,
I don't fucking know mean
I don't understand on a stand blaming him fucking year.
You know,
dude,
I just can't wait for this year to be over and then it's going to be 2017 I'm
not going to do any work on myself and I'll basically make the same fucking
decisions I made in 2016 but somehow 2017 is going to be better without me
having to make any effort whatsoever.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
why don't you just get out your rosary and say all your fucking prayers rather
than fucking making a positive step towards trying to make a real change.
MMM.
Anyway,
so let's talk about that Madonna thing.
When she was shaking her folks,
she was talking with that fucking woman,
Jesus Christ.
Unbelievable.
I just like,
I hate that she does that because it makes me feel old.
You know,
when she was,
she was all happy say,
hey a fucking day.
Anyways,
let's plow ahead.
This is not,
this is not why I wanted to do this thing here.
Um,
did you guys have a nice holiday?
Did you have a nice [inaudible]?
Did you have a nice chat?
Hanukkah?
Did you have a nice Christmas there,
Jim?
Hey,
Jewish people do.
Do you guys like how many you actually,
uh,
when I was a kid,
people who weren't Jewish told me how you guys celebrated Hanukkah.
And I realized,
well,
they weren't really Jewish where they,
let me ask you this.
Do you do,
how many people do the traditional,
is it a one day thing or is it like a nine day thing?
How many candles are on the manure is at the same as a baseball team.
And if so,
do you give fucking one gift a day for nine days?
Like total old school,
you know,
we're baking our own bread here type of thing.
Right?
Is that are actually,
is that a religious story?
Isn't that there's always bread.
There's always bread.
There's always fish.
There's a fucking leper,
you know,
and then there's always the one guy,
Abraham Muhammad or Jesus,
right?
Hoggin up the whole fucking budget.
Like the same way they make movies nowadays we're Tom Truth gets all the fucking
money,
right?
He gets all the fucking money.
And what about those character actors?
They I go fuck yourself.
Right?
You know,
back in the day you could,
you could make a living as a character actor.
You know what I mean?
Not Anymore.
That's not how it works.
Not In the age of,
uh,
the fucking superhero movies.
So anyways,
let me see how many days of Hanukkah.
Why don't I,
why don't I look this up?
Happy Hanukkah.
All right.
How many days in
I [inaudible]
is eight days
a days a week.
All right,
so it's eight days.
Sorry.
Nine guys on a baseball team.
Eight days.
Anaqua do you fucking give a gift?
Every deaths the traditional way as far as the non Jewish people told me that
they give a gift to date.
Now if you do that,
my question,
my question to you is,
how do you give out those gifts?
You know,
how do do you do it?
Like how I do a stand up set?
Well,
you gotta start with something strong.
You got to establish that you're the fucking man for the job,
right?
Yeah.
I don't mean to be sexist about that,
but when you really think about it,
men do a better fucking job just generally speaking.
You know what I mean?
Women have been nowhere near the fucking moon.
Okay.
And we were there like,
fucking how many of you that I'm fucking years ago,
where are we?
You know?
Oh Jesus.
I just thought,
I just thought of one of the worst fucking jokes ever and I will not say it,
but I'll describe it to you.
Okay.
I will describe it.
I can't do it.
I see.
The only way to get away with it is if Nia is here also laughing.
I was going to say,
you put the guys out in the space,
you know,
we get all the way to the moon.
You know,
you try to bring a lady up there,
right?
You see where I'm going?
I can't do that.
It says they have to Christmas.
I would not do that.
Um,
anyways,
eight days.
So what do you do?
Do you start off with the fucking something strong.
Okay.
You know,
and then you establish like this is the little level of gift giving and you
gradually start your ascent through days.
Two,
three,
four,
five,
six.
Woo.
Whoa,
we're going to another level is seven and eight.
You gave me all A's.
You're fucking gift now.
Fuck off for a year.
That's how I would do it if I was Jewish.
All right.
Me and Neil would Jewish and I had to get near eight gifts.
What would I start off with?
I'd start off with some shoes,
right?
Cause bitches be loving the Jews,
I give her the fucking some shoes then a Jesus Christ.
Fucking eight gifts.
Okay.
Yeah.
We got to go.
Go close.
No,
you know what?
I would start right out of the gate.
I'd start with something silly.
You know like her stocking stuff for this year,
like I know like she knows certain kinds of food she likes.
Like one year I told her,
like I said,
I know I'm going to get you for Christmas.
She could wait yet.
I'm going to go and eat.
I'm getting you a bag of Fritos.
Right.
She just kept laughing,
you know,
thinking it was the funniest thing ever that I wasn't actually going to do it.
So of course the first gift I gave her,
she opened it up,
it was a bag of Fritos and I gave her a big bear hug and I was like,
oh,
this is the greatest Christmas ever.
And she thought it was the funniest fucking thing ever.
So if we were Jewish,
that's what I would do.
I would start off with stupid fucking gifts.
Cause who's kidding who?
I'm not going fucking broke here.
All right.
Is it Christian?
A nonpracticing Christian?
I don't get my wife a gifts a year.
You know what I mean?
Dude,
you guys should do it like a game show.
Okay.
Do you want a pretty good gifts?
Uh,
one fucking great one.
That's like,
when you win the lottery,
do you want to it all at once or have get paid a hundred grand over 20 years?
And anybody who always takes the payments doesn't understand money.
And also,
you know,
it's just like,
well don't go to me.
Oh well it's,
I've got to blow it.
You get it all at once even though you were in a bigger tax bracket.
You know what I mean?
It gets you over the hump into being a fucking millionaire.
I don't give a fuck how much money you make.
If they give you 200 grand a year,
you're never going to get up over the million cause they're going to fuck it.
They got a tax the shit out of you.
They take it all at once roughly.
I mean,
you could do it if you just fucking set to written corn flakes and shit,
but like if you take it all at once and then you invest it,
but you're not going to know what to do.
They wasn't there.
A whole documentary on that.
I have no idea,
but my wife,
fortunately I'd like to give,
since you gave me this year and you know it was funny and made fun and getting
socks for Christmas and she got me socks that she was all embarrassed.
She goes,
he said it on Thursday that you didn't like saying I like socks.
I'm just fucking around.
There was,
that was the only thing in my stocking this year,
she bought me a little box.
Three pairs came in this little box a little,
he was gonna be cookies.
I opened it up with some tape.
Baker,
take his socks and uh,
I don't give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
Like I said,
I'm an adult.
You can give me a Choo Choo train.
Silver.
It's fucking over.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
okay,
I'll tell you this quick story.
Fortunately,
Nia light her gifts and I always have a little bit of anxiety whenever I give a
gifts because,
uh,
first my first girlfriend I ever had,
I think I told you this story before,
did I?
Um,
my first girlfriend I ever had,
I had to get her a gift.
Now I didn't grow up around the ladies.
I just said brothers for the longest fucking time.
Right.
And I don't mean black people.
I mean,
I mean I had like,
I was related to these people.
I had brothers.
Um,
so,
um,
this cough is never gonna go away by the way,
cause the fucker prescription I got,
you know,
just fucking put it down on the mat and now it's just fucking hanging around
like this thing.
They won't leave.
I know you guys are thinking,
oh,
he must be smoking like a chimney.
I'm not,
I'm not fucking smoking at all a slash I might be done with cigars.
Um,
and I'm Kinda,
I'm kinda done with booze too.
I,
you can't fucking do it anymore.
You know,
I love it and all that shit,
but I just hate waking up in the morning like old,
you know what?
I'm over hangovers.
Fuck you.
20,
60.
Um,
yeah,
I'll have like a beer.
I'll,
I'll have like,
you know,
uh,
one glass of Scotch at this point,
but I can't do the fucking,
uh,
I can't take the ride anymore.
You know what I mean?
And it just hit me one day,
like,
you know how quickly Brett Farve got old,
just done over out of the fucking league.
You know,
he hung around and he hung around and he hung around and then he took that last
fucking hit when he was on the Vikings.
You know,
it just looked like his clothes were just laying on the ground,
didn't believe there was a person,
you know,
and all the really religious people got all concerned that you know,
that they get left behind and it's like,
no,
that's what it looks like when a fucking 42 year old guy takes a hit from his
fucking defense event.
Um,
yeah,
I'm fucking done within all of that shit.
Uh,
however,
let me tell you the story that the first girlfriend I had,
so it was,
her birthday was coming up and I had absolutely no idea.
Okay,
what to get a uh,
a female.
Okay.
Should I go to the mall and I'm looking around,
I'm looking around,
I had no fucking idea.
And I came up to this table and they had all these polo style shirts,
nice shirts,
shirts I would wear and they were on sale and all that stuff and it just,
all these different colors.
So I bought her like four of them and I wrapped him up and I gave them to her
izods and Polo shirts and shit.
And she fucking unwrapped these things
and the level of disappointment on her face.
And she just was like,
what?
What is,
what is this?
What the fuck dude?
She just fucking went off.
She flipped out.
She started yelling at me like,
like a,
you know,
like a head coach mad at halftime,
I said,
kicked the ball,
you're kicked out by Tony Jacket,
you know,
flipping out on me.
And I literally did,
I was so embarrassed.
I like kind of put my head down.
I looked at my feet and they just sat down on the edge of the bed as she was
yelling at me.
Okay.
Right.
And uh,
I don't know what happened.
I like,
I was so fucking embarrassed and she,
you know,
I was young,
I didn't know anything about women and shit and she was just going off on me.
And about three quarters of the way into,
we're a rant,
which was really a good 90 seconds long,
by the way.
Which is fucking forever.
I think she was kind of coming to her senses that she was taking in what she was
doing to me by my body language and the fact that she just given,
gotten a gift and the way she was reacting and,
uh,
she started to try to pull back on the stick and be like,
oh no,
you know,
it's Kinda,
and that's when the anger fucking hit me.
That was one of the first times in my ute that,
um,
okay,
I actually address my feelings in the moment.
You know,
I was fucking one of those people brutally.
Like three days later I'd be like,
Hey,
wait a minute.
That person took advantage of me or that person was being rude.
I should have fucking said something.
Right.
Um,
this fucking wave of anger came up and,
uh,
I just,
you know,
handle it classically like the German Irish guy.
I am,
I didn't communicate anything.
I just stood up.
I walked over,
I started putting my jacket on and all that.
Now of course she's fucking know and you John Leave doing all that shit,
you know what I mean?
And all you want to do is the,
you know,
the swim move than a defensive lineman does.
You know,
you fucking pushed to the side and then you fucking bring your arm up and over.
That's what I wanted to do.
So of course,
now I'm walking towards the door and she does what all,
what every fucking woman does in that moment.
She's blocking the door and now she's crying.
She's crying,
you know?
It's like,
what are you crying about after everything you just said to me?
I'm holding it together pretty fucking good here.
So she's crying.
Now she's between the door and I say,
you know,
I want to leave.
I'm leaving.
No,
but look,
you know,
and then that,
then that said awful thing.
They stand in their whole,
none of the fucking door jam and you can't put your hands on them or else you're
going to go to fucking jail.
Even if you're just trying to remove.
It's so weird.
You know what I mean?
It's like you're a human being.
You want to leave the room that you're in.
You're in a free country.
There's another human being prevented you from doing it there.
They're holding you there against your fucking wheel,
but they're a fucking lake,
so
it's totally fine.
So what are you do
you just have to sit there and not looking them in the eye?
Just staring at the fucking door.
Like I'm fucking leaving.
You can stand here as long as you want.
I am going to fucking leave.
Right,
Ms. Brewer the key.
You can't,
you can't put your hands on and be,
can't even try to like,
you know,
with the outside of your arms.
So to try to,
you know,
kind of shoehorn your way past them.
Um,
cause then they start flailing around like deliberately trying to get themselves
hurt during the altercation.
So then you'll feel bad and then you won't fucking leave their fucking lunatics.
I want to leave.
Right.
Look at me.
It's still bugs me.
So you know what?
I swear to God,
you know,
I've always wanted to come up with something that you could sell for 1995 late
at night and all these mouth breathing fucking morons.
They think Trump's going to make the fucking planet great again or fucking or
United States great again and all these fucking dumb bras.
I thought that because Hillary also had a vagina,
that somehow their life was going to improve those fucking morons.
Right.
And is yet another day of disappointment has gone past and they fill themselves
up with buying absolute shit for 1995 I've always thought,
how can I take advantage of these people for $20 a pop?
And I,
you know,
every time I've come up with something I find out somebody else has already
invented it.
Like I came up with this fucking thing that you know,
you stick between the car seat and the console,
so every time you drop something it doesn't go between the seats somewhat
already came up with that.
Right.
That was the only thing I ever came up with.
But somebody already came up with it.
So it'd be great if for like 1995 you could come up with a device that gets the
woman away from the fucking door so you can fucking leave when they're blocking.
It would,
that does not involve like hurting them or her at any point.
Also being able to say that you put your hands on,
so I figured there's like,
I dunno,
I don't what you have like you have like giant fucking like these nerf hands.
Okay.
And you just put them on either side of her,
right.
Then once you stick them on and they just stick on,
like,
you know when they have like those plastic explosives that you just slap on the
side of a tank.
It's like once they're on you,
they're fucking on you.
You're going to owe or a new shirt.
All right.
But at the end of the day,
that's worth,
worth the fucking price of just getting the fuck out of there.
Okay.
So you put them on either side of her and then you have,
you know,
those blood pressure pumps as a youth [inaudible] now she can't fucking move,
and then then you,
you,
you got an inflatable be bay,
right?
And then you just guide her over.
You put it down on the fucking bean bag,
you open the door and then you fucking bring the blood pressure pump just to the
outside of the door.
You close the door and right as you're about way to close it,
you release it,
see closed the door,
and then you're fucking right to your car,
right?
You know that thing where you're fucking running any,
if you feel lightheaded and shit and she's going to become running down the hall
after you announced,
like you're in a horror movie,
you're trying to get your keys out and he or she fucking comes,
you get in the fucking car.
Hopefully you get the car door close before that fucking lunatic comes up to
stick her fucking Armand.
You close the door,
you lock it,
and then you know what she's gonna do.
She's gonna stand behind your fucking car.
Then all you do is you just start the car up,
right,
and then,
and you're revved the fucking engine.
Get those admissions in her face.
You listen to some tunes.
Eventually she's going to have to go to the bathroom and who knows?
Maybe an hour later,
maybe a fucking hour later,
you know,
you get the fuck out of there,
right?
1995 I can put that in an infomercial,
not even infomercial.
That's too much money.
I can do that in a fucking 32nd spot,
right?
Fellas?
Have you ever wanted to lead your girlfriend's apartment but she won't let you?
What do you do?
You've tried moving her out of the way,
right?
She yells,
fucking rape that the cops coming and fucking tackle you and showing you in a
cell with a fucking giant cell mate looking at you like he's going to bang you
in the ass.
Right?
That's the first six seconds of the commercial and I think you guys can do the
rest of it.
Maybe that's a reason to have a four wheel drive vehicle,
so when she's like a standing behind you,
you can't back out.
You just put it in drive,
go right up and over a curb.
I don't know.
I guess what I'm really getting at here is I hope you guys all enjoyed your
holidays,
your nice fucking days off here.
You know,
it's spent so long since I've had a day job yet.
Do you guys have to go back to work today?
That's sucks man.
You know the day after Christmas,
you right back.
And then,
let's see,
what is it?
New Year's Day is what?
It's Sunday.
Yeah.
News days.
Sunday.
But then they played the bowl games on Monday.
So maybe next weekend you get the fucking three day weekend.
I have no idea.
All I can say is fuck you.
2016.
Glad this year's over me.
And um,
you know,
a while ago when they came up with the College Football playoff,
somebody play off.
Somebody asked me to comment on it and I was too fucking busy editing the God
damn show.
I never really looked at it.
Um,
and it just dawned on me that Ohio state is in,
in Penn state is out.
How the fuck does that work?
Okay,
somebody please explain that to me.
Yeah.
Penn State won the big 10 championship and they beat Ohio state.
Penn state's in the fucking Rosebowl and Ohio State's in the playoff.
And I've got a friend of mine is a buckeyes fan and he's bitching
but Alabama schedule
fucking he's wine.
It's like,
dude,
you should even be in there.
I,
Allstate should not fucking be in there.
That makes no fucking sense whatsoever and all you fucking concert,
we're going to go,
well Alabama had a real easy schedule.
SCC suck this year.
So what SCC was the,
the whole fucking year was basically playing a national championship game like
fucking two,
three times.
They,
the,
the conference was that good for 10 years?
Alabama had to fight through all of that.
So one time they get an easy year.
Um,
anyways,
having said that,
I'm still rooting against them because you have to,
they're so fucking good.
It's fun.
And I told you my favorite thing in sports,
Alabama down at the half and then Nick Saban has to talk to one of those
sideline reporter women,
you know,
he,
all he wants to do is fucking slam some lockers.
It's chew out as Punter Asub Shit.
And he's got to sit there.
Like I'm telling you,
if anything is going to put that guy in an early grave,
it's that fucking interview we asked to do.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
I don't,
I mean I'm not like Anti Ohio state,
but that does,
that does not seem fair to me at all.
How does a team that didn't win the big tent,
it didn't even when they're fucking conference championship is in the final
four.
Yeah.
It's all bullshit.
It's all fucking money.
It's all money I owe.
State is going to get better ratings.
I bet it's going to give him better ratings than fucking Penn state.
Other than that,
it makes no fucking sense on paper.
You know,
and I loved those kids that are going to sit out their bowl game,
but he's just so good.
Sports talk radio guys.
It's like,
dude,
it's fucking slave labor.
Remember that dude on Ohio state played that fucking Penn state,
uh,
was a willing to [inaudible] gay.
He got his fucking knee blown out for free.
Cost him a career in the NFL.
If you didn't have such a great fucking agent,
um,
yeah.
Fuck you.
You're going to sell,
sell a Jersey with the kid's name on it.
You're gonna make millions more.
The fucking players are selling out 100,000 seat stadium and don't get a fucking
dime.
Figure that one out.
All those players throughout the fucking century of the damn team that have
created the excitement gone out.
They're blown out their knees,
got concussions,
got paralyzed,
died early.
Fucking deaths.
Do not get one dime.
Fuck you and your bowl game.
They got to start giving these kids money,
man.
It's fucking brutal.
It's brutal.
And I love all the fucking nerds that actually go to class and they get mad at
the athletes because they don't show up.
It's like,
Hey,
fuck head.
If it wasn't for that kid out there,
you would,
you would have a class in a tent right now.
You know?
What do you think paid for this?
This fucking biology classroom?
Huh?
People showing 100,000 people showing up to look at you.
Look through a fucking microscope.
A tent.
All right?
You don't have a sexy job.
Deal with it.
Right?
I don't get it.
Having said that,
I'm still gonna Watch and um,
I dunno,
I like Clemson too,
but,
uh,
I don't know.
I'm kind of a big 10 guy too.
I probably still root for house state,
but that,
that's so funny.
It doesn't make any fucking sense.
I mean,
there's always going to be a reason to complain because football's such a
violent game that they can't have like march madness.
They just can't be too many fucking games and too many kids get hurt,
right.
So
every year someone's going to get mad and,
uh,
so I usually blow it off,
but this year Penn State got fucked.
You know,
I mean,
maybe it's leftover sin Dusky Shit.
You know what I mean?
Like not enough time has gone by.
Just going to pause here to listen to all the Penn state fans go la.
Okay.
You know,
it's funny.
Is the fucking Tom Brady deflate gate story lasted longer than that Sen Dusky
Shit.
And that's the world that we live in.
Um,
okay.
All right.
Let's get to some of the questions here for this week,
shall we?
Um,
oh,
how about the fucking Celtics man?
That's Celtics Knicks game was great.
The NBA too,
by the way,
Bravo for saying,
all right NFL,
you get thanksgiving,
we get Christmas.
They actually muscled the NFL out of position on a football Sunday to the point
that all the fucking games are on Saturday,
Saturday.
Well there any NFL games yesterday,
I didn't even look.
The NBA Games was so fucking great.
I missed the first one.
I watched the Celtics and Nick's great fucking game.
Then we almost blew it.
And here's the funny thing is Michael Rappaport still owes me dinner from the
NBA finals and that cause he's a cheat motherfucker or anything.
It's because we're both fucking busy and we just,
we run into each other like once every six months.
Self,
Celtics to play in Nick's on Christmas Day.
And I saw,
I texted him,
I said,
Hey Mike,
you want to go double enough?
I'll take the Celtics straight up.
And he goes,
absolutely.
And then he goes,
wait egos.
So if,
if I lose,
do I owe you two dinners?
I go,
no,
you owe me breakfast.
You owe me dinner and now you owe me breakfast.
And then we'll bet on the Superbowl and if I win,
you know,
if you,
if you win,
you don't owe me shit.
And if I win,
you owe me breakfast,
lunch,
and dinner and you're gonna fucking take me out.
We're going to do a youtube video of you taking me out on the town for the
entire fucking day.
And uh,
so he said,
all right,
so he's in.
So what I'm hoping is that there's going to be a patriots giant fucking the
trilogy.
And,
uh,
of course I'm taking my patriots and I'm hoping this is the year that our
defense does it let Tom Brady down.
Cause the first two times we played the giants,
He drove them at the Patriots down the field for the go ahead score.
Both times he is six foot six and super bowls when it is counted right.
The time with Donovan McNabb fucking throws up Nilo Donald throws a pic,
Peyton manning throws a pick six.
Tom Brady has manned up all six.
He's gone six.
Oh,
unfortunately his defense has gone forward to,
um,
so I want to see that rematch.
And,
um,
of course I'm going to take the Patriots and I,
then I texted him,
I said,
okay,
so the Patriots and giants play each other.
What's going to happen?
Are the Patriots going to go oh and three.
Okay.
Oh,
the giant is going to go into the giants.
Gonna go three now.
Okay.
Against the Patriots.
Or is Michael Rappaport going to go all in three against the menu?
So hopefully that's going to happen.
You know,
I want the Patriots to play.
We'd go back to super.
We have to play the fucking charts.
I don't give a fuck about Seattle.
We already played then we already beat him.
I don't give a fuck about anybody else.
We gotta we gotta go back.
You got to do it.
You know,
I've talked to some fucking patriots fans.
They'll go,
oh my God,
that makes me sick to my stomach.
So what are you gonna do?
You're going to quit now you gonna put your Paul Revere had between your fucking
legs and go home.
You know,
I think the biggest thing this year is as their coach,
even though the coach is doing like a good job and everything,
but you know,
I dunno,
I just don't,
this is so stupid.
I just look at a coach,
I judge a book by its cover and I just look at that guy and I'm just like,
yeah,
you know,
I'm not feeling,
I'm not feeling this guy.
This guy just looks like a,
it looks like a diehard giant's fan.
That's what he looks like.
He does not look like a uh,
a head coach.
Um,
so anyways,
we shall see.
And I told you I'm not buying into,
I don't buy,
don't buy.
I'm,
I'm not,
I don't believe in the cowboys.
I don't like to coach.
I look at him,
I'm like,
I do not lie.
Just don't like that guy.
Not like personally don't like him.
I just look at him and he just doesn't look at your head coach
like a head coach.
You got to look at them.
You got to be like,
Oh man,
I would not want to get yelled at by that guy.
I know you guys to think of what about Pete Carroll?
Pete Carroll looks like he's going to Bible study.
Yeah,
but if you look into he,
he,
Carol has shark eyes.
Okay.
I'm telling you that fucking guy,
you know,
I'm not trying to put rumors out there,
but if that guy had like a dead hooker in his past,
okay.
Or at least,
you know,
one that lost consciousness and he brought her around,
it would not surprise me.
That is so fucked up to say,
I'm sure he's a hell of a guy.
All right,
let's get,
um,
let's,
uh,
let's do some of the advertising here for the lads here for the weaker,
right.
Um,
all right.
See,
so everybody Siso is the place for comedy.
They won't tell you how amazing they are,
but I will see.
So is amazing.
It's comedy for comedy nerds by comedy nerds.
Cso Spelled S.
E.
S.
O.
N.
It is the new ad free streaming service.
Bring you original series,
handpicked classic weeks of standup specials in more bingeable comedy.
Anytime,
anywhere on Seeso,
every episode of SNL,
including new episodes,
the day they air.
The tonight show starring Jimmy Fallon and the end late date with Seth Meyers,
the day after air,
and they even have classics like 30 rock parks and recs saved by the bell.
Even British comedies like the original office were fricking sure vase.
He's drinking a beer.
Oh my God.
The entire money python catalog,
the it crowd and Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge.
Am I supposed to know who the fuck that is?
Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge.
No Way.
That's his better as a hairy Hamill is Steve Rabinowitz,
critically acclaimed originals and exclusive content like Harmon quests created
by comedian Dan Harmon and funny as hell a variety show featuring comedians such
as Jim Jefferies and Hannibal Burress.
If you're serious about comedy,
you've,
you've got to try CSOS streaming anytime,
anywhere and for all right.
Let's get to the point in a CSO is ad free and just three 99 per month.
That's less than you paid for the,
uh,
that latte or artisan cold brewed coffee you're holding right now and right now
my listeners can try see,
so for free for two months,
when you use the Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout,
uh,
shows you can't get anywhere else from critically acclaimed original series to
all 40 years of SNL.
Dude,
fucking how much money is Lauren Michaels making off of this?
He's got tonight show starring Jimmy Fallon.
That's one of his boys late night with Seth Meyers.
That's one of his boys.
30 rock.
That's one of his girls parks and recs.
That's one of his girls say by the belt.
I don't know.
He's probably got something with screech.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com right now to sign up for two months for free with
the Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout.
That's [inaudible] dot com promo code.
[inaudible] Ah,
here we go.
But it will do to me undies,
Mija,
Andy,
he's wearing a man after Christmas,
but who do to me undies?
Biondi these,
you know,
want to fuck in miss this.
Does that rhyme?
Okay?
You fucking balls will feel nice.
I ain't got nothing this week.
I don't know where.
Why did I pick Christmas?
Let's start and take two,
take two.
Right?
[inaudible] softare Sanas Beard Badu,
dude,
do me undies Mondays.
No one will call you.
Queered when you have his beard up against.
She had not seize Robyn on your tastes and your ass is,
you'll feel great during the holidays.
Skip around returning the gifts that you didn't like.
All right,
me undies.
Picture a world we're putting on a pair of underwear isn't just fresh.
You stepping into a better day.
Think about it under,
where's the first thing you put on in the last thing you take off?
Unless you Matthew mcconaughey,
why would you settle for anything less than the best selling best feeling
underwear on the planet?
Uh,
me undies focuses solely on producing the most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced.
Evidently he doesn't ride up and your ass.
They're my friends too.
I've never met how somehow we're friends at [inaudible] sent me a few pairs of
while back.
Oh,
what you want you to think that's all you got to do to become friends with me on
that superficial.
Um,
it really makes each day better when you were the son to wear for the price of
two cocktails,
cocktails me undies.
We'll deliver your new favorite pair of underwear right to your doorstep.
Try them on if they're not the most comfortable,
best feeling under where you've ever had the refund.
New led to keep the first pair for free.
Included in the included in the price is the sweet touch of modal,
especially Motel Modelo,
special fabric made of the best in class raw materials that are scientifically
proven to be three times softer than cotton.
That's Uber Cozy undies are sold exclusively on the [inaudible] website where
you'll enjoy shipping for free in the US and Canada.
All right,
and for a limited time,
everyone,
everyone in my audience gets 20% off their first order,
but you have to go to our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash per with the Mondays better day guarantee.
You have nothing to lose,
so don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash go right now to for 20% off your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash bird Jesus fucking Christ.
Those ads are so overwritten.
All right,
hold on one second.
All right.
I'm back.
I'm back finally to fucking clean.
My goddamn throwing.
You want to happen.
So I woke up this morning,
but do we do dude,
and I just started doing the podcast because I got do a bunch of shit today as
always.
As always.
Uh,
hey Billy Balden Billy bald.
Dan,
do you get it?
Billy balding business.
Billy Bald.
Dan Is Brava.
I heard you ranting about how New England keeps offloading defense defending
players.
You're half right.
But this year is a big year for salary cap dot.
What do you mean?
I'm half right.
Name one person that has finished their fucking career with the Patriots on the
defensive side since fucking,
uh,
Teddy Bruschi or fucking a Willie McGinest.
We never keep them.
I'm not half right dude.
Richard Seymour lawyer Malloy Thai law,
uh,
who's a big fucking,
um,
oh my God,
I can't believe I forgot his fucking name cause they're only with us for a few
years.
Who is the Big Fat Guy?
Our,
our,
our nose tackle.
He's God.
I don't know.
Anyway,
so you said you're half right.
Dante,
hightower,
Malcolm Butler,
a bolt in their mid twenties and in contracts years.
Expect both of them to get big contracts in the off season.
I don't expect that.
I don't expect that at all.
Maybe one of them will.
So what you're saying is I'm half right.
You're saying expect them.
So on your forecast,
I'm telling you what has happened.
You're saying on your forecast you what you are you what you are projecting that
that's,
that's one of your points.
Okay.
Your first point is out the fucking window.
All right.
That's science fiction there.
Okay.
Expect to see both of them get big contracts and I've seen Patrick Chung,
the strong safety is 30 now and we have a great young backup and Landon Collins
who was also in a contract year.
Okay.
So expect Patrick Chung to get the fucking evo cause he's 30 and now it would
probably be like,
Hey I'm a veteran of play in this league.
I've demonstrated that I can do that job and that's when they go,
okay fucking see you later.
Finally the pro bowl free safety,
Devin McCourty is getting top dollar dollar.
So it isn't just the offense.
Okay.
So in all of that shit you just said,
you only named one guy who's getting top dollar.
Okay.
Everything else was projecting shit.
Right.
Hope that brings some clarity to Billy super bowls.
Pretrade deadline move sending Jamie Collins,
another middle linebacker entering a contract here who was underperforming
compared to hightower.
Thanks for a great podcast.
Underperforming.
All right.
What,
well,
like how you,
I like how you ignored uh,
uh,
Chandler Jones who's having a fucking pro bowl year with Arizona.
Um,
you basically told me that Devin McCourty is getting paid.
That's basically what you told me.
And um,
they've always paid guys who were in their mid twenties.
What I'm talking about is that next contract,
that next one.
They're like,
yeah,
get the fuck Outta here.
You Audio Patrick Chung.
Get the fuck Outta here.
All right.
Um,
here we go.
I mean,
look,
as much as I'm complaining it is working,
but it does get frustrating to see these guys that she shut down this side of
the field and every couple of years we get rid of that guy.
And um,
like I always feel like,
you know what,
I always feel like our defense,
you know,
since the McGuinness frable and a teddy Bruschi years,
I always feel like it goes in,
it's like my pie,
it looks like it's done,
but inside it's still soupy,
you know?
So when we go up against the giants,
I just feel like we don't know.
Those two times we went up again,
we didn't match up well against them.
They had a monster defense,
you know,
we're coming in there.
You know,
we had Leanna,
I just,
I dunno,
I love I,
that's why I love the giants.
I love the Chinese because they always have a great fucking defense.
I always have a great fucking defense.
I that,
you know,
that's why I like the Steelers.
Back in the day,
they doomsday defense,
the cow was,
you've got to love those teams.
You know,
cause then you're on offense can just be like good and you're going to win the
fucking game.
That's how s fucking now Mark Sanchez,
everybody who asks,
they started calling him Sanchez.
They're fucking defense was great.
Then they lost everybody and all of a sudden,
you know,
uh,
USC boy there didn't,
couldn't just manage the game.
He had any had to play from behind.
And he's like,
Eh,
where did it go?
Where did it go?
And he runs right in the fucking ass of his linemen and got a concussion.
Well,
you would've got a concussion.
No,
I probably didn't get a concussion.
That guy probably did too many squats as acid.
Probably like an elbow.
Alright.
Podcasts inspired girlfriend to quit job that was making her miserable.
Oh Jesus Christ.
There should be on the Oprah Winfrey network.
Are we,
are we actually going to have like a feel good fucking story here?
Fuck is going on with these blinds.
Open the blinds.
Okay,
what did we get here?
40 minutes in?
Okay.
Somebody's got to stretch this shit and do another 20 minutes to ignorance.
Well,
Bill,
you've been doing great for the first 40 minutes.
All right.
Podcast inspired girlfriend quit job that was making her miserable.
Hey,
Billy.
Bill,
a chick.
Um,
my girlfriend and I love the podcast and we listened to it together and whenever
we're on a long road trip,
a few months ago,
we put on your interview with Joe Rogan.
Uh,
when you guys started talking about jobs,
you hate it and how you knew,
uh,
and how you had to,
to know when to walk.
My girlfriends started crying.
Oh,
Jesus.
Up to that point,
I knew that she had issues with their job,
but had no idea that our company was putting it through so much grief.
Um,
so much grief that it was making her absolutely miserable deep down inside.
Once you heard the interview,
it convinced and inspired her to take action as quickly as possible to seek new
employment.
Good for her.
Yeah.
And that's a great habit to get into and you do it when you fucking young
because you don't have any kids.
No wife,
no husband,
no mortgage.
That's when you fucking make you moves.
I'm not to say you can't do it after that,
but it's obviously um,
you know,
there's,
there's no reason not to do it when you're young.
Okay.
Now she's on the right track for a really great job and the possibilities of a
permanent hire with a really good companies seem to be in the works of seem to
be in the works.
Knock on wood,
I would like to thank you Mister Rogan for not only providing us with great
entertainment but also in inadvertently helping out someone I truly love and
care about to seek a positive work environment.
Dude,
is there going to be anything I could make fun of him.
This,
this is just like a nice letter.
She is also,
she is already in better spirits than ever before and it's in part thanks to
you.
Hope to see you come through the Carolina's next time around.
Thanks again and have a wonderful holiday.
Well that's great.
All I can do is reiterate.
I can't even remember what the fuck I said,
but yeah.
Um,
you know,
I had a friend of mine that was working for,
uh,
was working for the Nestle company.
I think it was Nestle.
It's one of those fucking corporations and they will running this person ragged.
And I literally watched this person go from a positive person to somebody that I
started to avoid his phone calls because like it was getting so fucking
negative.
And then,
uh,
one day this person just said,
fuck this,
quit and actually started working for like a nonprofit and was happy as fucking
hell and is now back in the corporate world at a company that he fucking loves
in.
Like,
you have to fucking do that,
man.
You don't,
if that whole fucking fear of like,
you know,
how am I going to pay for Shit?
We'll keep you in these bad relationships with these horrific fucking companies.
Right.
Um,
but what she had,
you have to always be willing
to sacrifice for your own happiness.
And if that involves downsizing your fucking life and just getting,
just looking at all this shit on your shelves and all of this stuff that you
fucking have,
it'd be like,
how much of this shit do I even fucking need?
Cause I'm sitting here,
you know,
in our guest room where I have all my drum videos,
my magazines,
all these fucking books,
they've just sat on the shelf for fucking years.
Like if you literally took everything off of this fucking shells,
okay.
Other than the sentimental value of a few fucking things,
I wouldn't even,
you can empty all the fucking,
those little cabinets if you emptied all of it other than when I walked in and I
didn't see it,
I wouldn't miss any of it.
Um,
except for I have the 1970,
is it 1972.
It's the most expensive years of football cards.
Um,
I have the complete set that I would miss,
that I would miss.
It was a couple other things I got up there.
But other than that,
I said,
you know what,
I'm,
you know what?
I'm going to get rid of all that fucking shit.
But a downsize my fuck.
I'm saying you can do that.
Think about when you first fucking,
you know,
moved out of your house.
What did you have?
You had the clothes on your back,
couple of piece of shit,
things of furniture,
right?
And then other than that,
just over the years you get subscriptions to magazines.
Just say they just start collecting shit.
People give you stuff,
you go and fucking trips and you buy shot glasses and then all of a sudden what
you really yet your house is just this giant storage shed for a bunch of shit
that you don't lead.
Eat your apartment becomes the same way.
So
if you downsize all of that to get out of a fucking job,
you don't want to be in and you reduce your fucking overhead in the meantime,
you can actually make less.
You know,
there's all different ways to get out of the job,
starts spending less,
saving up fucking money so you can quit your job and live for for months without
having to fuck at work or whatever.
Or making a little bit less money.
In the meantime,
just get rid of a bunch of shit that you don't even fucking need.
Um,
I got to do that with the baby coming any fucking day now I gotta uh,
I gotta get rid of a bunch of shit cause God knows she's going to have a bunch
of shit too,
right?
Uh,
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
here we go.
Let's fucking,
let's,
let's plow ahead here.
A return.
Gifts.
All right,
dear bill,
I got to get into a debate with my fiance.
I got into a debate with my fiance.
She seems to think it's rude.
I don't wanna be rude.
It seems to be rude to ask someone for a gift receipt for a gift they did not
like.
MMM.
I told her that it,
it'd be worse to keep the gift and never use it then to return for a better size
of something different altogether.
I take you for the type of guy to just say thank you and throw it out if you
don't like it.
Good call,
man.
I actually,
if I don't like something,
I would never die.
I just don't do that.
I just,
uh,
I take it down to goodwill.
Um,
I got a jacket from my aunt that I don't like and doesn't fit.
She thinks I should just exchange it for a proper size and call it a day.
I know for a fact that my aunt wouldn't be offended because we're close enough
that I can tell her that thoughts on this,
you know.
Okay.
This is one that I,
it's up to you.
I think it's a good exercise to tell somebody what you're really feeling,
uh,
at the price of their feelings.
I just don't know if it's with a Christmas gift.
MMM.
I think you could do it once to somebody,
but if next year,
if they come back with something ugly again,
then you're just saying,
you know,
you have bad tastes.
But,
uh,
I don't think there's anything wrong with it.
And,
uh,
if they look,
I gotta be honest with you.
If I got somebody a fucking gift right now,
if they didn't start screaming at me and make me sit down,
like if I ever gotten,
if I ever get my wife a gift,
she was like,
you know,
I don't like this.
Can I exchange?
It would be I can't fuck.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Here's the receipt.
Have fun going to those crowded malls.
I'm done.
I,
I've fulfilled my end of the,
the verbal contractual agreement that we have that I will buy you a Christmas
gift.
But you know,
when you go to return the fucking thing,
I mean,
that's on you.
You can go back in there with all those fucking animals again.
I'm not doing it.
Um,
yeah,
I don't think there's wrong with it.
I think that that's,
maybe that's a preference thing.
You know,
if you,
if you want to fucking,
okay,
do you want to go that route?
You know,
God bless you.
You go that fucking route.
If you don't,
I respect that too.
Um,
all right.
I slapped my sister when Christmas Eve.
I don't believe this.
I don't believe this at all.
Dear Billy Bitch tits.
I'm bitch tits.
And you slept a woman.
Um,
hey Billy.
Recently my family celebrated my dad's birthday,
which is on Christmas Eve.
And like every year we went to a local Mexican restaurant.
My mother bought him a very expensive bottle of Middleton triple distilled Irish
whiskey.
Never heard of that ship.
A hope I said it right,
which we proceed to drink once we returned to my parents house.
All right,
how many of you are on this bottle?
And there's a woman's slapped in the end of this?
Jesus Christ.
This is like a fucking country music video.
Once we were back,
my sister who's 30,
asked if she could collect pictures of us as little kids,
she could make an album.
I see it.
I knew exactly where some great ones were of her as a baby and my mother's
drawer where she,
my mother had previously shown me.
Um,
you know,
I don't know what's going to happen in this thing or if it's even a true story.
But I'm already saying at some point somebody should have said fair enough
before somebody gets slapped or key goes,
my sister has a different father than I and from what I gather,
her dad was a not so great guy and my mother doesn't seem to have any fun
memories of that relationship.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
I presented the pictures to her expecting her to have either seen them before or
to be thrilled to be seeing them for the first time.
The pictures were of her and her father with my mother's family.
Um,
I'm getting lost here.
Okay.
Yeah.
You guys have the same mom but different dads.
Okay.
Also,
her birth certificate was in the certificate was in the envelope,
which she apparently,
which apparently she had never seen.
She's 30.
She never had a produce,
a birth certificate.
When she saw them,
she freaked out.
She began to berate my mother for never showing them to her in a full blown
fight ensued.
Of course,
I was mortified.
I had no idea this was going to happen.
Um,
I'm going to go out on a limb here,
sir.
When I say at this moment,
this is not about you anymore.
Okay.
I mean,
she didn't have a good relationship with her dad.
This could be,
you know,
something that she needed or something that seems to be between her and her mom.
And if you're going to go third man in,
and that's a game,
his conduct and I would say a fucking 10 games suspension at least.
Uh,
she said horribly hurtful things to my mother and tried to storm out once I
stepped in and tried to stop her.
Oh Shit.
Now you're doing that thing,
so need this product tow.
Fuck.
I'd make a zillion dollar the male or female
person remover.
Yeah.
How ignorant am my then I never thought that a woman ever had to fucking try to
get through the door with some fucking asshole guy,
Stan,
my apology and all the ladies.
All right.
Once I stepped in and tried,
uh,
once I stepped in and tried to stop her,
she began to attack me and shout out everything that was wrong with me and my
life.
I defended myself yelling back all the fucked up shit she's done.
Um,
that's not defending yourself,
sir.
Which you did was you went to her emotional level,
which you should have done was just laid on the fucking ropes,
let her go,
and then afterwards she would have owed you an apology,
a.
Anyways,
he goes then with Mike,
this is,
this is why you don't go home for the holidays.
This shit always ends up happening.
Then with my mother and father there,
she charged me and punched me square in the eye with this insane look on her
face while she wanted to leave and you weren't letting her.
I was trying to keep her at arms length and telling myself over and over don't
hit her.
The final Straw came when with both my parents trying to hold her back.
She managed to kick me in the face with their boots on.
Aren't you standing up?
How the fuck did she do that?
Oh,
they held her back and tech gave her leverage.
Her sister,
she like Anderson Silver and she just gave you that front up kick.
The didn't see whatever the fuck you call it and MMA terms.
Then I proceeded calmly and coolly to pick the exact moment when to reach in and
give her an open palm slap right across the whole left side of her face.
You did that calmly and coolly.
Oh,
Jesus.
She immediately stopped a tirade and went in her car to pout.
Well,
I have dude.
He slapped her in the face.
I don't think she's pouting.
She later chilled out and fell asleep on the sofa.
Christmas being tomorrow.
I need your help.
Did I do the wrong thing and how can I keep things from being fucked up from
here on out.
Thank you.
And Go fuck yourself.
Did you do the wrong thing?
You slapped a woman?
Yes.
I mean,
she's coming at you with a knife then.
Yeah,
you can go close fisted at that point.
But I mean,
all she was trying to do is leave.
Um,
here's the thing,
dude.
She had
a valid reaction to something that really hurt her.
Okay.
In,
in her pain.
She said a bunch of mean things to her mom.
Okay.
All right.
Now she comes from a broken home.
I mean,
this shit's going to happen during the fucking holidays.
You're fucking drunk on whiskey.
You write you guys a few.
From what I can tell,
there's only two of you on that bottle,
maybe three or whatever,
but you know,
three,
four people killing a bottle of whiskey,
you're all going to be hammered.
All right?
Um,
then she wanted to leave.
Yeah.
Now she's drunk and she wants to drive.
That's one thing.
He did not put that in there.
If she just wanted to leave to go be by herself.
There's nothing more frustrating than when you're hurt and you're emotional and
you want to leave.
A Roman people won't let you leave.
It's fucking annoying.
All right.
If she has no history of trying to hurt herself,
she's not drunk.
You got to let her leave.
Um,
the fact that you just said,
you calmly coolly waited for the fucking exact moment to reach in and slapped
her across the face means you contemplated this shit.
It's like she hit you and then you reacted
and did it.
You made the decision,
you thought about it and you waited for them.
So that went from like fucking second degree to first degree.
Um,
so yeah,
no you didn't do the right thing and you should,
I would feel terrible if I fucking did that.
Um,
okay.
And how can you stop things from being fucked up from here on out?
Uh,
okay.
Well I would sit down and I would just keep playing over and over again how it
escalated and you kind of zigged every time you should have zagged and just try
to think of what you can do the next time.
But uh,
calmly coolly picking the exact moment to slap your sister in the face on
Christmas Eve.
Okay.
Yeah.
I would say you did,
you did the wrong thing.
I mean,
like I said,
literally,
unless she was literally going to be doing physical harm.
Okay.
To,
uh,
well I guess she hit you felt God,
that's so fucked up.
Okay.
I'm not even thinking that she kicked you in the face and she did all of that
type of stuff.
Okay.
Um,
I still got to say,
cause they were holding her back.
It's just one of the things that women get to get away with.
They get it,
they get to get away with the salt better.
And you,
she like,
you shouldn't fucking hit him,
but I'll fucked up.
Is it that even as a guy,
I wasn't even validating the point that she kicked you in the face?
Yeah.
And uh,
punched you square in the eye with an insane look on her face.
I think it's very easily for me to be sitting here in bed,
not emotionally invested in any of this to say whether the fuck you did the
right thing or the wrong thing.
Um,
you know,
you got a,
a,
your family's gone through a fucked up time.
You throw alcohol in there and some old fucking pictures and uh,
you know,
your sister,
puts her hands on you when you hit her back.
I mean,
I dunno,
I dunno.
I would have to look,
maybe could you said you calmly and coolly pick the exact moment when to reach
out.
I don't know.
Maybe that's what fucking threw me off.
But like,
if this all went down and like fucking three seconds,
uh,
you know,
I think you guys all need some fucking group therapy.
Um,
all I can say is I'm glad I wasn't there.
I'm glad I wasn't at that.
Yeah.
Party.
That's all I can say about that one.
However,
I do feel that I owe you an apology for judging your actions without even taking
any consideration that you took two hits to the head,
to the face.
You hit me in the face.
Right.
Um,
okay.
And you know,
I've seen women like that and I know how hard they punch and kick and all that
shit and they have no concern
for the fact that they wearing shoes and they kick you in the face.
So just said,
you know,
they way over a hundred pounds in,
who wants to get hit by somebody weighs a hundred pounds right in the fucking
face.
You don't.
And that the natural reaction to getting hit is to hit back and they got that
whole,
well cause I'm a girl.
You can't do it yet.
I can just fucking
break all the fucking rules in the,
you know,
it's,
it's one of the things,
but you know,
something I,
okay.
Maybe that's just one of the,
one of the perks you get for being a woman,
you know,
they got to have their period every month.
They got to go through fucking labor.
You know what I mean?
They got to get all those free drinks.
They always get the house during a divorce.
I mean,
there's a lot of things that they have to go through that maybe,
maybe it's okay that they can hit us.
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
all I know is that,
you know,
if a woman ever hits you,
you just,
you just fucking walk away.
You just walk away.
And,
um,
if they're not related to you,
you just end the relationship like this is over.
Yeah.
You know,
W are you coming back to woody and get me a gift now?
Where am I?
I'm,
I'm like the battered woman now and we're like,
oh,
we'd,
she's usually not like that.
She shuts a good for us to go fuck yourself over.
Um,
all right,
so what I would do a file.
Okay.
Did I do the wrong thing?
Anica how can I keep things for being fucked up from here on out?
Um,
okay.
This is what the first thing you could do.
I would not drink whiskey around volatile family members.
Uh,
I wouldn't do that.
I would try to be the sober person.
I think if you were more sober,
I,
you probably wouldn't have done that.
Or at the very least she would have saw the punch come.
It sounded like she threw a straight right.
You know,
you have made a little slip that you know,
fucker with,
sorry that that happened.
And uh,
you know,
I dunno,
you guys kind of evened out.
She hit you twice.
You only hit her once.
Said,
maybe that's fair.
Who the fuck knows?
I don't fucking know.
But I,
I don't,
I don't buy into that whole chivalry thing that,
you know,
that once somebody starts swinging on you,
it's,
they've,
they've fucking,
you know,
they've waived all rights of chivalry and,
uh,
in rules between the sexes in my own opinion.
But like,
it's the fat.
It's,
but for the guy though is,
is if he reacts immediately,
I give you a pass.
But the fact that you've thought about it,
it shows to come back to,
even though she deserves it,
she's still a lady and then you don't,
I mean,
personally,
I could,
uh,
well I guess he never say never,
but I've never run into that.
And I've had a lot of women hit me.
I mean,
I'm an asshole.
I've had a lot of women hit me.
Uh,
I've had women throw shit at me.
Um,
but it's never a,
it's never gotten to that point where I,
I would,
I,
I couldn't do that.
She's a bill.
It's like hitting a fucking kid or a dog or some shit.
You know,
I couldn't,
I couldn't do it like an animal.
They're defenseless.
You know what I mean?
Unless it's like Rhonda Rousey,
who's fighting this fucking weekend?
Everybody,
you know,
fuck.
If you,
if you're,
there's a question for you.
You're dating someone who is not just takes karate or fucking MMA shit is
actually in the UFC.
That,
what does that become?
You know what I mean?
If she fucking hits you to say you survive that.
Okay.
Oh God.
There's not a woman who's even remotely thought about getting into the UFC.
That couldn't kick the shit out of me.
I can't imagine fighting one that was actually in the UFC and be fucking
hilarious.
Then later,
they're apologizes.
I have a stake over my eye.
I'll make it up to your freckles,
right?
Ex girlfriend is a cunt.
Jesus fucking James Blunt here.
Hey Bill.
I am a lady and a huge fan of yours.
I love Nia as well.
Uh,
get her on the case if possible,
please.
Oh,
well she's still downstairs sleeping.
Okay.
I dig other ladies and recently I broke up.
I broke a very important relationship in my life.
I was dating this girl on and off for many years and felt totally in love with
her.
Um,
all the while she claims she loved me more than anything,
uh,
was she still does claim,
by the way,
and says,
I am the only person she has ever wanted to spend your life with.
However,
she's one of these people who just needs her freedom and can't function in a
fucking relationship.
Well,
then you got to let it go.
Uh,
before we broke up,
we had this huge fucking argument about commitment and I said,
I didn't see the point in continuing this relationship.
She reflected on it and said,
I was absolutely right.
That I don't deserve to dedicate my entire life to someone as complicated as
her.
Well,
yeah,
I agree with her and walk.
I agreed.
She then said she tried but can't reciprocate my feelings in the same intensity.
All right.
That was eight years before this broad was jerking me around saying I'm the love
of her life.
And she wanted to marry me and live with me forever.
All these years,
every time I confronted her about her troublesome behavior,
there was never cheating at least.
Uh,
she didn't tell me,
hey,
I don't think our feelings match.
This may not work.
She led me to believe she loved me enough.
Uh,
she's still saying I'm the love of her life and whatnot,
but feels horrible for all the pain she's caused me and the time I wasted.
I said,
being in love,
the love of her life wasn't enough to make her act like a good girlfriend.
And then I wanted to move on with my life.
So we parted ways.
Good for you.
Strong move.
I like that move.
Now I'm not sure what to do,
where to start.
My identity is so intertwined with this intertwined with this person.
You know,
we used to be in the beginning,
I want to start over,
but I don't know who I am outside of this relationship.
I like to hear your thoughts about it cause I think you guys give some good
advice.
All right.
I would say this,
what you're feeling is totally normal.
And what a lot of people do is when they feel those feelings of like,
well now what do I do?
Who am I?
How do I pick up the fucking pieces?
There is that initial feeling,
which does not feel good and your natural reaction is to go for the quickest
fix,
which is to go back into that fucking horrible relationship.
What you have to do as the song goes,
you got to walk through the fire here.
I would write down,
you know,
I would start a journal and something so you can kind of,
it's something to just be feeling your thoughts versus writing them down and
then you can see him and then you can kind of get outside of yourself,
which is what you need right now.
And you know,
friends help with this too.
We have to be like,
look,
you can't go back to this person.
You know that.
Okay.
But right now is like the worst part is now you're going to be lonely and
heartbroken by yourself.
And this person that usually conferred you is the cause of it.
So you can't go to them for comfort because it's going to fuck you all up and
get you back to square one.
So,
um,
okay.
You're asking me what you should do is I think that you should
acknowledged the fact that you're going to get you what you have to go through
some pain.
You're going to go through some pain over the next,
like you know,
certainly three months.
But what you do during that time is you gradually build a new life without this
person.
So the first month you're going to be in the fetal position crying and just,
you know,
going through the neck,
shoulder,
psych.
So I went to detox of this person.
But what I would try to do is introduce a new fun activity.
You know,
that you could do like,
I dunno,
whatever the fuck it's into,
even if it's like a fucking TV show,
the emit to binge watch.
Something as simple as that.
That is something that you do.
And in that it's yours that you don't do what this other person.
And then you just introduce something else when he ready for something else.
Maybe you always wanted to learn how to ride a horse.
Go fucking do that.
God knows she got the God damn time,
something fun.
But there's something that you've always wanted to do,
but she didn't have the time with work.
It being involved in relationship.
Go do that fucking thing.
Take a trip,
do something.
And all the time when you feel INSEAD given to the sadness and cry some of that
fucking paint out.
I'm a big believer in crying.
Um,
it's something that guys are not allowed to do.
It's why women get past shit and guys carry shit.
Women's still can look back and see the sadness,
but they're done.
Finland fucked up over cause they didn't hold onto the emotion.
They let the emotion out.
Guys hold the fucking thing.
And like,
I believe that guys should,
you know,
cause it's too embarrassing for people to see us cry.
They should in every house,
the way you have a bathroom,
a bedroom,
a kitchen,
there should be a crying room for the men.
He goes into,
closes the door,
it's soundproof.
And he's allowed to go in there,
in whale out all of his fucking pain,
the way women are and everyone flocks to them and hugs him and gives him
comfort.
And,
uh,
you know,
I'm a big believer in it now than after,
after half a century holding it in.
I believe that you should fucking let it out.
He should go Chris Bosch if you're a guy.
Um,
so that's what I would say to you and just acknowledge the fact that this is
going to hurt.
I'm proud of you that you got out of this relationship,
you know,
eight years of this person jerking you around and you know what you did.
You got out of something toxic and you opened the door for the right person to
come into your life.
You know someone that's going to respect you and make you laugh and you have a
great time,
you know,
and one day you can look back on what the fuck did I waste eight years with that
person?
And you know why you did.
So you can realize how great the person that's going to come and see you life is
going to be.
And there you go.
There's your pep talk.
All right,
you can do it.
I believe in you.
All right,
here we go.
Let's read the last two fucking ads here and then I got to get the folk adhe.
Here are right.
Um Oh blue apron.
Everybody.
Hey is something you could do.
By the way,
if the person who just,
I just read because one of the things you might want you might do is eat a bunch
of food and put on fucking weight.
You don't want to do that.
You know?
That's like another being another bad fucking thing that this person created.
They broke your heart and now they're going to fucking put more stress on your
heart because you're going to eat bad food.
You know what it'd be great to thing is he ate healthy meals and you know what?
You're crying.
You're in the fetal position.
Would it be great if somebody just brought the food to you?
Blue Apron.
This is like the fucking,
this is the best move you can make.
If you go through a breakup right here,
blue apron,
they're going to bring your healthy food.
It's easy to fucking cook.
You going to stay in shape,
right as you get over that fucking last asshole at con.
That was in your fucking life.
And a,
you're going to be a good shape.
Does baby attracting somebody else in your life?
Who knows,
but do not just jump into something.
I forgot that part of the advice.
Do not jump into another fucking relationship.
I would stay after an eight year thing.
You need to stay single for at least a fucking year,
I would think.
Uh,
and that'll make you so fucking strong.
You,
you,
you'll be looking back on,
I can't believe I used to be that other person.
Okay.
Blue Apron.
Not all ingredients are created equal.
Fresh,
high quality ingredients make a real difference.
So it's an important to know where your food comes from.
Uh,
it's affordable for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes along with proportion of Greens to make
delicious home cooked meals.
Choose from a variety of new recipes each week or let blue aprons culinary team
surprise you.
Recipes are not repeated within a year,
so you never going to get bored.
And it's flexible.
Customize your rest,
your recipes each week based on your preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options.
So you choose what fits your needs and there's no weekly commitment so you only
get deliveries when you want them.
Each meal comes with step by step,
easy to follow recipe card and pre portion degrees and can be prepared in 40
minutes or less.
Blue aprons guarantees,
promise,
promises that every ingredient in your delivery arrives.
Ready to cook.
All right,
here we go.
Um,
this is,
I get check out this week's menu and get your first three meals for free with
free shipping by going to blue apron.com/burr a that's blue apron.com/burr blue
apron.
A better way to cook.
And lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com you don't have time to go to the post office post
office.
So what do you do?
I use stamps.com instead with stamps.com you can avoid all the hassle man of
going to the post office during the busy holiday season.
Then the mailman picks it up.
I use stamps.com to send it out.
All my posters when I'm on the road.
Trust me if I'm a moron,
if I can figure it out.
So can you,
it's that easy right now.
Um,
I can get you a better offer from stamps.com and what's on the home page.
Sign up for this for a stamps.com and use my last name,
bird to get a four week trial plus a $110 bonus offer,
including postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone at the top of the homepage,
type in burr that stamps.com enter [inaudible].
All right,
that's the podcast for this week and joy,
um,
between the Christmas Hanukkah,
Kwanzaa in the new years and lets it go.
Fuck yourselves.
And I'll check in on you on Thursday.